hallöchen männer lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
christmas kräftig habe diesmal die
einblendungen aus versehen gelöscht von
der letzten folge und zwar wollte ich ja
in dieser folge und in der nächsten
folge noch den weihnachtsmarkt weiter
bauen wo ich hier schon angefangen habe
also ihr seht dort schon die eisbahn die
ich schon angefangen habe hat mir
übrigens eine bei facebook geschrieben
haig ob er gar nicht rein oder nicht
stimmt wenn man jetzt hier besteht kommt
man eigentlich gar nicht rein datei ist
da mach ich jetzt einfach so
dann haben wir ein eingang danke an dich
die mir das gesagt hat und ich wollte
ruhig sagen ich muss hier stehen packen
weil sonst sieht es da wieder peters
hirt aus eingang und ja ich wollte heute
sagen dass sich die einblendungen oben
links diesmal nicht drin habe die werd
ich beim nächsten partnern
wahrscheinlich auch nicht drin haben und
hier gings wie heißt es meine stimme ist
ein bisschen schlecht wegen weil ich auf
klassenfahrt war und irgendwie hat man
eine stimme
meine stimme ist halt gerade irgendwie
tut dass du irgendwie alles weh wenn ich
rede oder so ich denke dass heute auch
ein wenig und dritte sache die ich sagen
wollte heute ist ja der zehnte dezember
wenn ihr dieses video seht also wenn ich
es auf dem center dezember abends 21 uhr
ich habe nun alle kommentare durch
gekippte ziemlich alle unter einen
christmas kraft folgen das war teilweise
2000 kommentare unter die ersten folge
glaube ich das war schon krass wenn man
bei euch mal was gewinnen kann
kommentieren sie sofort allen spaß
jedenfalls wollte ich euch nun die drei
gewinner vorlesen und zwar an die drei
gewinner dass wir zu ablaufen ihr werdet
heute abend wahrscheinlich gegen 20 uhr
oder ein bisschen später auf jeden fall
heute noch von mojang minecraft
angeschrieben der euch dann der das dann
halt mit euch regelt also kontrolliert
bitte euren posteingang und guckt dass
dadurch als sie kriegt dann ne pn von
minecraft und ja wenn das nicht wenn ihr
die nicht irgendwie nicht riecht dann
schreibt mir am besten dann regel ich
das mit ihm aber eigentlich sollte es so
sein dass die drei gewinner die ich
durch vorlesen werde
die sollen einfach mal heute abend ein
paar mal ihren posteingang checken und
ja ich lese ich ziehe mir das mal hier
kurz ein bisschen hoch und liegt nun vor
und zwar erster gewinner jetzt warte ich
muss das mal ganz gut hier reinschreiben
ich kann dinge aussprechen das ist der
erste gewinner gsv hj dkl wahrscheinlich
einfach mit tastatur und seine
geschichte vor und werde dabei versuchen
einen kleinen markt zu bauen und zwar
ach ja ich wollte ja beim paris hin
bauen
ich musste man als kind und werde ich
mir ein bisschen wohl und dann bricht
hier bräuchte noch das brauch ich den
brauche ich den brauche ich und dass ich
musste mal als kind 13 jahre
weihnachtslieder auf der gitarre vor
spiegeln
ich habe mich vor dem baum gesetzen
gespielt ich war wohl ein bisschen zu
nah am baum also zu netten die kerzen
meine gitarre an alle waren außer sich
holten wasser außer meiner oma die
musste ich an warum tust du denn schon
die kerzen am adventskranz an
dann mussten wir alle lachen obwohl es
eigentlich nicht so lustig war
wir bekamen die gitarre doch noch
gelöscht omar es bis heute nicht
also das war wohl ganz witzig und zwar
mit dieser geschichte durch lese denke
ich mir echt zu alter wie blöd kann die
sei nichts gegen dich aber das ist schon
so ein bisschen holen na ja also das ist
jedenfalls die erste erste gewinne und
zwar findet eigentlich als 40 g zweiter
ist super minecraft forum brauche ich
rein schreiben
ich habe einen kumpel gegen bob fahren
wir fuhren mal irgendwo anders durch und
dann fuhr ich runter und ich bemerkte
dass dein theilig ist und sprang vom bob
und der bob viel in den teich ich wollte
aufstehen da kam mein kumpel und form
ich fuhr in mich rein und dann waren wir
zwei plus zwei bobs im teich
das war ganz so häufig bei der
geschichte erst lesen dann waren wir
zwei bobs im teich also ich dachte eher
wenig mit bob gefahren sondern ersetzt
nicht mit dem bob gefallen mit diesem
bob ding wo man sich drauf setzen hätte
sein freund halt total der bob wer weiß
ob man wirklich als beleidigen
beleidigung also zumindest bei uns ja
also auf jeden fall auch eine sehr
komische geschichte was wiederum zeigt
wie blöd die leute einfach nur sind
sorry aber das ist eigentlich bei jeder
geschichte so naja also finde ich auf
jeden fall auch ganz witzig dass es der
zweite gewinner und der dritte gewinner
vielleicht ist es ja du dir das hier
gerade sieht
es ist german rita tv ein paar freuen
und ich haben vor letztes jahr eine
schneeballschlacht gemacht und dann ein
schnitt gemacht und hat nicht gesehen
dass er schnell genommen hatte hat in
dem hundescheiße war de hat er dann auf
mich geworfen direkt ins gesicht und
dann mein gesicht voll mit schnee und
scheiße hat auch zwölf download der
software namens richtig gefeiert dass er
ins gesicht bekommen habt und ja also
dass er nämlich wirklich immer noch an
die geschichte die ich euch in der
ersten folge erzählt habe dass da mein
cousin scheiße also pizza gegessen hat
das natürlich sehr sehr witzig naja
jedenfalls das sind jedenfalls die drei
gewinner ich muss mich hier kommt ein
bisschen konzentrieren und zwar weiß ich
gar nicht was ich überhaupt wieder für
eine kacke bauen es ist ja wieder so
unglaubliche so also das wird jetzt
einfach zu sagen es sind so häuschen
ich weiß nicht genau wie man nicht wie
ich das darstellen soll
waldkirchen dafür ein für den rand nehme
ich nehme einfach stone sieht irgendwie
ganz cool aus so als menschen die
eigentlich wer holz auch ganz gut
gewesen aber ich glaube so kann ich das
einfach anbieten so dann mache ich hier
noch so fenster rein da übrigens ich
nehme immer glas weil glasscheiben finde
ich irgendwie nicht so schön
das heißt wir nehmen da so das ja ich
glaube das kann ich sogar so machen das
dann wiederum führt dann passt es da
wiederum nicht so in den boden mache ich
aus holz ich muss gucken wie viel ich
mache weil leute folgende sache ist also
ich hab halt für diese folge kein thema
weil ich halt die dings vorleser diese
leute halt die gewonnen haben
und die sache ist die ich schreibe also
wenn ihr dies mit ihr seht ist der
zehnte die schreiben der am 12
die klausur und am 14 die klausuren also
ich glaube ich hab das jetzt richtig
gesagt york 12 10 14
ich schreibe am zwölften englisch und am
dann schreibe ich sowie also
sozialwissenschaften heißt dass sport
doch nur zwei hütten ich weiß auch schon
aus welchen farben weil das ist sonst
ein bisschen zu lange wie folge und sie
aus dem schlumpf ist hier nur dass also
die an beiden baue ich dann in der
nächsten folge nächste ende übrigens
bauen könnten hin wollen und das heißt
dass ich nicht versprechen kann das in
dieser woche immer christmas kraft kommt
also sollte es erst mal ausreden und
zwar schreibe ich jetzt bis zu den
ferien dass er noch zwei wochen also
zehn tage in diesen szenen schultagen
schreibe ich vier klausuren und ich
denke alle die irgendwie von euch in die
oberstufe gehen die wissen was für ein
stress eine klausur ist also wie viel
man dafür wirklich der muss das ist
nicht damals irgendwie sowie eine arbeit
oder so dass man da eher kurzen tag
vorher sich einsetzt hat lernt das ist
eine klausur ist da schon so ein anderes
kaliber sage ich mal kaliber 69 beste
rap portion spaß jedenfalls ja also ich
habe ja gesagt tourismuschef kommen
jeden tag aber ist ich nehme jede folge
wirklich auch an dem tag auf
beziehungsweise einen tag vorher und die
sache ist dann einfach die dass ich weiß
das projekt kommt super super gut bei
euch an ich hätte nie gedacht dass es
wirklich so gut ankommt und die sache
ist die ich muss auch irgendwie die zeit
finden und mit sport und fahrschule was
hier mittlerweile alles noch nebenbei so
happ und halt auch lernen für die schule
ist das echt eine menge stress die da
auf einen zukommt wenn man jeden tag ein
video macht und deswegen habe ich auch
mit pfeffer schon so eigentlich ganz
cool projekte welche gestern den wir
alle zwei wochen zwei stunden auf oder
so und da kann man sich das echt richtig
gut einteilen also dann muss ich die
sache wirklich nur bearbeiten was heißt
nur bearbeiten hochladen arbeit aber ich
hab echt wenig zeit im moment für
youtube allgemeinen deswegen kommentiere
ich auch nicht so viel und leider auch
nicht so viele shows von ihm welchen
dings
motz texmex oder so hoch aber den
weihnachtsferien geht es dafür dann
richtig ab da habe ich richtig viel zeit
weil da will ich zu hause fahren nicht
in den urlaub
das heißt da werden menge videos kommt
in den weihnachtsferien
und ja ich wollte euch nur jetzt hier
mit sagen dass wahrscheinlich diese
woche weniger christus treff kommt bzw
nächste woche denke ich schaffe ich das
schon irgendwie das hinzukriegen oder so
nur ich kann euch halt nicht versprechen
dass e mails also dass jeden tag
christmas kraft kommt wenn ihr versteht
was ich meine
was für die teile muss nur ausleuchten
wenn ihr auch einige sommer wegen das
kloster und verwenden
das kann ich jetzt eigentlich machen
also ich kann euch nicht versprechen
dass jeden tag christmas kraft kommt
aber und wenn ihr übrigens infos
erfahren wollt über wo ich bin was für
fotos ich poste zum beispiel habe ich da
also erst mal wenn ihr wissen wollt dann
leicht mich auf facebook den link ist
immer ganz oben in der beschreibung und
zum beispiel habe ich letztens legal die
ich die story die ich euch jetzt
erzählen wir was mir so ein weimar
passiert ist also ich war auch stufen
vaters erzähle ich euch einfach in der
nächsten folge schaltete einfach ein
oder schaute bei facebook glaub ich die
stoffe auch schon gepostet was mir
passiert ist fand ich echt ziemlich
witzig und naja jedenfalls würde ich
einfach sagen dass uns am nächsten folge
sehen
schaffen wir 1000 111 likes also 1 1 1 1
das wäre echt hammer geil weil ich seh's
immer ich schreibe immer soja schafft
die 500 und am baum 1700 likes allgemein
richtig geil wie aktiv in letzter zeit
also schaffen wir 1000 111 likes ist
werde ich richtig richtig hammer dann
will ich sagen sehen uns in der nächsten
folge wieder
ich habe dann in der nächsten folge noch
kein thema und aber ich behalte noch den
weihnachtsmarkt zu 1 und danach geht's
dann wieder weiter also wir sehen uns in
der nächsten folge und liken und
kommentieren wenn ihr auch ein spiel
gewinnen wollte